hey how's it going breasts welcome oh he
come back oh don't what do you mean go
home we're friends for life now Steve
says you almost killed me
Oh maybe here's going where are we
anyway where the hell are we
this is cool man those tires in the sky
my favorite thing to put in
damn that is epic we gonna go up there
are we gonna go all the way he's dancin
Dan Susie Holocaust occurred in okay
or the do Roku to Z we are no more to
cut to neck our cozy
[Music]
the wings are broken clearly they're too
small he waves like a [ __ ] time
sorry no offense Oh Noddy how to to kill
Anita
I'll go cruzi I'll do to cool oh the
heart of the beasts lair the nest
what uh ok well s guess my um I'm gonna
go here never mind there's nothing here
or is there oh my god this is terrifying
it's very cool but very scary alright
let me jump up on you oh my god that
looks terrifying what the hell hey hey
alright I'll be going this way whatever
I don't care
babbit a bat bat better or let's take it
real easy real nice and easy tip tap a
tat oh hey what's this look like a lever
I'm at it keep tip tap added to but if
habited Hey look at that
look it's safer this way
why did I just do that I think he's
going to join hey stop
don't worry about it right is he gonna
jump on those because if you do that you
know a plus I'll be really impressed
no he's distracted by Birds great
fantastic what a great [ __ ] pet I
ain't managed to keep yeah keep yelling
at the birds Treecko
you're doing great I don't know oh he's
doing it he's doing oh my god
alright Treecko you mate okay you've
done it now boy stop following me
Treecko more like two craves oh good one
right great stop oh well you've done it
now okay somehow that's still standing
alright well third one you're not gonna
make the third one I'm sure I'm sure of
it why am I such a dick
oh here we go how making me look bad
Treecko I don't like it oh I'm done flip
ji sad
okay well I'm you know show off okay
we're in the heart of the nest an
ancient city what happened here right
all right well hey would you mind if I
uh oh hey it's you best friends right I
wonder how our relationship would
develop with this bird I'm so excited
about potential friendships oh I got it
clipped away and that's why I [ __ ]
that okay weekend Oh
Oh li mo oh oh I thought I had a bridge
Bert no hey it goes there perfect that
seems safe now that's that's a bridge
that I think looks safe I am definitely
going on this one that seems like a
great idea
ah ah ha ha
oh the anxiety Jesus alright now your
tank are you just walking look at in Hey
look at that wasn't that hard what's the
big deal your [ __ ] I shut up fine I'm
going this way now just following the
light love that love the light on the
camera there it's pretty okay well it
looks like we can go through here
I'm bet we're gonna get up end up in
there to Turin where I used to play soon
I have a have a good feeling about it
hey Bette look at this so cool oh my god
everything this is amazing hahaha
dude you're too fat come on man I'm
almost out come on help me pull damn it
dude you're too fat I don't know dude
I'm coming back Jesus please I'm stuck
help
god dammit alright fine
know what fine why are we going oh this
looks like it could be it what is that
long as he's been late hey troika you
just need to get up here we're calling
him CID responding at all hey hey it's
oh my god I spoke peopIe how did you get
up there oh I see no problem just jump
up here man hey I'm taking my damn time
here shut up is he gonna do it I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do it
just watch Bo my god you are so smooth
really great John alright this way
follow me try to keep it what does he do
I wonder what the food does I mean gives
him strength but ah but it's drugs it
looks like it looks like some Heisenberg
[ __ ] you know are you ready 3 2 1
catch oh we did it yeah that is awesome
alright come on body come on trikha I
made you high on drugs like you better
keep up it plays beautifully I'm that
was one of my concerns with like playing
the demo but I'm really enjoying this so
far so it's more intuitive I'm told
there are many ways to solve puzzles in
this game that's it yeah keep going
oh he's gonna jump oh no oh no ah
ah that's it ha ha see if we can jump
from his ass that's a sentence I didn't
wish I said ok well there you go maybe
there's some benefits from giving your
pet cocaine like maybe it will pay off
in the end who knows I don't know man
I'm loving this so far it's so fun to
play [ __ ] you in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this game worst game I ever played
what the [ __ ] was that dude is that a
salamander that's a salamander Oh
Treecko don't step on salamander Draco
what are you doing there salamander
right there don't drag oh okay hey look
who came to help huh yeah I know that's
I guess I got to be more careful with my
jumps from now on I really didn't think
I would mess that up there it is ha ha
too bad [ __ ]
aw come on Mae you're trying to get the
high sand break you better come back
here boy don't worry about it all right
so where should we be going yep here
I'll be right back ok don't worry about
[Music]
whoa is this where we started no no no
no ok it's different it's pretty have a
little foot bath see if we can find some
drugs tunes you know motivate that seems
to be what the only thing that works
with this [ __ ] pet I'm still love
pissed about the tribal tattoos you know
hey you made it you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
oh my god is that it's that butterfly is
that the brighter flesh I think I might
be too fat to squeeze through here here
you go you just eat it all right fine I
don't care
listen up I just need your ass literally
I'm dude literally you're gonna eat it I
mean if I went through all the effort
you're gonna [ __ ] eat the candy
alright alright catch there you go
that's my trick oh that's a trick oh I
hate myself okay there we go let's shoot
this come on quick though hot coming out
of my ass
there it is good job Treecko good dog
I'm not a dog what am i doing okay Hey
look at this that's cool
well I guess I'll go through in this
tiny little hole how convenient that I'm
the small one babbit I bat bat bat bat
bat up a bit of a pepper bye bye Treecko
don't need you whoa whoa it's almost
like you can smell the nature but boats
you forgot him look at the reflection
whoa
you forgot about the best part me they
just jump over oh my god here I come
what's up it's your boy tree to the co
sorry oh it's amazing this is [ __ ]
amazing salamander can you do anything
with his salamanders cuz I remember
eight where the [ __ ] did it go I looked
away one second cuz I remember what is
it hey I got an idea
hey hey hey salamander you want some of
this nope oats nah under merchant power
he's fine
what that what what what
man this is emotional plane I I'm like
dead inside so this is pretty amazing
dude this is incredible
okay so where were we where do we go oh
come on you left without me [ __ ] dick
really
what hey now you see how it feels
what's happening he's backing up
it's a scared of something I scared of
something
hey poached it's jacksepticeye's penis
here oh boy it's coming back okay that's
my boy
surprise okay so I was right we were
gonna go up here it's just like he's
like an actual pet it's like annoying ah
dude was not ready for that man
my god could've died what am I looking
at here no one knows okay we did it come
on come on
like a dead approached oh it's one of
these he's scared of these let's push it
down hey you know what screw you [ __ ]
you step the guy why does he appear in
every one of my videos this is getting
ridiculous
there you go you're welcome track where
Oh what do we got here what did you just
fart disgusting all right I'll go in
here I'll take care of it
you don't know a we got dude I got some
high some burgers over here look at that
perfect look I got your favorite snack
Shibata flashlight huh that was the
sense everyone thank you very much hey
Troy I got a treat for you it's been a
good boy huh me me I've been a good boy
yes yes yes yes yes that's it
here you go ahh what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you could that be the Heisenberg
they say is this [ __ ] good this is dank
I don't know that this is not dank right
you got a fork what is this
you want me to feed it Hey whoa Jesus
[ __ ]
er mine oh okay all right then well I'm
going this way now okay where are we now
where Abid I'm coming poached oh hey
okay well are you coming or what
I'm assuming that say yes you really get
so immersed in these kind of games it
really feels like you're part of the
world and I think that's why I love it
so much you don't need things happening
every second you don't need to be
killing enemies you just want to feel
part of a different universe that's true
you know that's why I play games I want
to be immersed in a new experience I
really I don't know okay whatever don't
mean to me oh I see there's a window up
there Hey look what I found
did it all by myself boats okay alright
just stay stay there stay there and look
pretty oh I always do I asked the
guarantee puck here we go stay yeah
that's it that's it that's it stay there
stay here we're here oh you want to hear
there it is okay wait there okay sure
whatever just bring back the cane
wink wink it's trucks huh oh my god that
was closer than I expected so where do
we go
directional jump let's just keep going
all the way I'm calming Trika my man my
man so okay no it's the cameras
direction okay good to know
now drop down we did it uh whoa Jesus
Jesus Jesus Jason how do I get down here
okay here we go
let's do this nice and easy that was the
nicest easiest way I've seen now does
this open somehow let's follow this Hey
oh hey coach thank you so much higher
prick wow that looks real cool it's
almost as strong as me that gate I'm
sure okay sure whatever
let's Hey look at that we got drugs oh
my god
is that what I think it is that a
[ __ ] pot oh my god
oh my god it's that oh my god OMG
can I please can I please have one okay
if you've been a good I've been a really
good point
he looks like that muffin dog you know
that dog that I got denied muffins on
YouTube got him a little more delicious
Thank You precious alright don't worry
I'll take care of this with my [ __ ]
home by the vein you're welcome that'll
be another hide some breakfast oh here
we are this is the place we saw in the
beginning this is cool okay so what do
we do here chiriku doesn't like it okay
look at him um not feeling great about
this I think we should go the other way
then what it's matter with you why is
her eyes not able you know to go to qu I
dude I wanted that much god damage we go
do you think I can jump down I can't
okay what the [ __ ] is all this
all right later Treecko it's been spin
real okay so we got open this somehow
not a problem we can do this base to
seize chica what's wrong
here we go something happened what the
hell oh he did come down whoa whoa
what's happening oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my have him go
Jesus Christ what's happening okay okay
oh no he's not on our side anymore is he
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh No hey hey don't look at me like a
post you look like a keep smack no
please
aah what is he doing what the hell pochi
looking real tasty right now god damn it
I forgot you were such a jerk he's being
controlled he's been mind-control well I
have this member he's eating me what Wow
I'm gonna have to end this episode here
thank you so much for watching
it's been a pleasure I'll see you
tomorrow with a new one if you promise
to leave a like and I'll see you it and
yes breakfast
[Music]